okay hallo meine Freunde ich bin Laser
Luca der gute alte Freund von neben an
ich sitz
hier ich weiß nicht soll ich jetzt sagen
dass ich
la ich bin Sel Sand hi was geht meine
Damen und Herren wir nehmen tatsächlich
mal wieder eine nicht lachen Challenge
auf wo Sandra noch nie so ganz den Sinn
verstanden hat richtig aber wie vielte
ist das milliardenste nicht
lachen ich schwöre dir heute kein fragen
Geschichte wahr ist ich muss sie
enttäuschen sie liegen daneben sie ist
freifunden Red Bull Verleih Flügel auch
ohne Zucker aber nicht dass ich hier im
KF noch abhebe wacker wacker wer wer wer
Spaß muss sein die S auf den ersten aus
wie Angel
Merkel meine Mutter
[Musik]
beleidigen Hal
kein das ist wieder richtig dein Humor
fin was
lustig nein nein
ich versteh
nicht
bin
das ist ja so geil du schreibst Leuten
im Liv unlogische Sätze und sie sind
verwirt du die Musik immer so oder ist
das so irendwie immer alles
gut das die Musik von FIFA FIFA immer
oder bist du immer so oder lieber
nicht ne man SPI andere Spiele KLE hat
die was die braucht oder wieder immer
das ist so geil ist die wieder so immer
oder keine
Ahnung sch du da Komis
Fragen so Leute ich zeig euch jetzt mal
wie ihr aus dem Auto immer Frauen
ansprechen könnt das klappt immer hallo
hallo und wenn sie guckt dann macht ihr
so ja hallo wie geht's dir
bruderang der ist so lustig willst du
mit dem
einfach mal live gesehen so krass so
krank kennen ihn das ist der Luca mit
seinem geilen
Porsche jemand grüßen W soll ich
grüßenmand den du gern hast ich grüß
Maria Mar wenn du das Video siehst Top
10 top D Legenden aus nicht lachen
Bruder stell mal vor du hast mit 20
Frauen Kontakt ne dich verlassen aber
alle bis auf neun mit wie vielen Frauen
hast du dann noch Kontakt mit den
Mädchen die mir immer treu geblieben
sind
Frankfurt ja ich weiß du findst nicht
lustig weil es ein tiervideo ist ist wie
nice ist das Tierquälerei du ist diese
Dinger gehen das ist der
Witz ich darf nicht danke dass
soärst noch mal
an wie Spinne irgendwie auch ne oh mein
Gott lacht wie
du oh mein Gott ja beim fchen setzt
Carmen Ihre kompletten
Türkischkenntnisse
ein kompletto kom kom blau Hals Strauß
blau Hals aber was ich nicht sehe ist
ein blauer Hals das ist weißer oder
höchstens grauer Hals was machen wir
dagegen s töten wir
sie ich kann nicht mehr und ich muss ich
muss ich weiß nicht was ich muss aber
ich kann nicht mehr und ich möchte
ich weiß es nicht das nicht mehr West du
Lust mit mir vielleicht ein Ei zu essen
die Mama hat mir welche gekocht sehr
schön ich hol sie einfach mal
raus kann
etwasuern brauche ich dir schon nicht
zeigen ne so pass auf 60 Sekunden Timer
du darfst nicht ja und nicht nein sagen
Antwort in vollen Szen 40 € sind für
dich auf die Plätze fertig los so Zeit
läuft siehst du ja
danke
wie ich verstanden wenn ein Ei 5 Minuten
zum Kochen braucht wie viele Minuten
brauch auch 5 Minuten sicher ja wenn das
in eine gleich Taste ist was SST
dumal behindert behindert wie viel eine
Eier eine
Eier ein X 5
5 ich liebe
[Musik]
Frankfurt ganr Frau heißen sie ja Frau
sie dürfen nicht ja und nicht nein sagen
Sekunden lang
okay ja 3 2 1
Los Frau
ja
okay sie dürfen nicht ja nicht nein
sagen
okay ja nicht nein nicht ja und nicht
nein dürfen sie dürfen sie nicht sagen
okay ja für für 50 Sekunden 3 los Frau
ja
sie dürfen nicht ja und nicht nein sagen
egal ganz kurzand stirbt nicht sie meint
das nur als Ausdruck weil sie sehr
lustig findet los
fr hallo
ja verlor uns geht gut im
Endeffekt solange das Paper reinkommt
noch paper nicht reinkommt ist alles
GU Gucci wenn paper reinkommt paper
nicht reinkommt geht Gucci klar nen ich
dich dann Udo lass dich nicht überfahren
hier was wieder live ohne Ende gestern
ja ja
ja Peter zwegard wie geht's dir Peter
zweger kennst du den noch diese Anwalt
von RTL früher diesen schuldenberat oder
wmer das war ich wünsche euch noch ein
richtig schön boah du bist so ein
ekelhaftumoch wenn es euch gefallen hat
abonniert meinen Kanal und klickt boah
alter das ist der hat noch nie so
schlimm gerochen
boah der steht aber ganz schön dein Furz
hier gerade ne kannst du mal die
Schnauze halten Leute ich hoffe das
Video hat euch richtig gut gefallen und
lasst dem Video doch mal keinen Daumen
hoch und falls ihr mein asmr Video von
Laser l mir sehen wollt schreibt in die
Kommentare Sand ist übrigens auch den
Marathon gelaufen deswegen hat sie die
Medaille umh ja klar ich bin ja nicht
dumm darf ich haben Spaß